Afternoon, Julia.
You know my pronouns.
Are they them?
How you doing?
Yeah, um.
Thank you for telling me your pronouns.
I use correct grammar,
so the only.
Only thing I would need to refer you to is to your face would be you.
But I'm. I'm not being rude.
You can choose your pronouns.
You can choose what you want to call yourself,
but you don't have.
You don't get to require me to use incorrect grammar
and factually incorrect things.
You're not a plural.
You're a. You're a.
You're one person,
and you're a. You're a female person.
So I will use she and her,
thank you very much.
Do what you like,
I guess. No,
you won't. You didn't need to tell me then,
did you?
Maybe I'm just making sure people know
in case they're watching and they wanna refer to me respectfully.
Is it disrespectful for me to use correct factual grammar?
It's not incorrect or on factual grammar to use singular they
them pronouns to an individual.